i want you to sign up for dollar shave
club by going to dollarshaveclub.com
forward slash norm you will get high
quality razors sent to your door
that's not come on it's a little
frightening
i wouldn't mind it do you ever run out
of razors and you're like damn it yeah
we can't run out to the store yeah well
you don't have to here because you get
high quality razors sent to your door
every month and it's for a fraction of
what you pay retail even better also
makes a great gift for father's day is
your father still alive
no god damn that's two out of three he's
dead too yeah
hi i'm patrice o'neill you may see me
laughing at all sorts of things but the
one thing i never joke about
is the seriousness of residential
mortgages
hey if there's one thing always on my
mind it's low percent property finance
but like you i don't have the time to
number crunch my option the way i'd like
to
that's
[Applause]
how to read [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] up though
because this is funny me reading this
even if i'm dead serious this is [ __ ]
up this is why i don't work
it's in tritium
a place i like to call home
what [ __ ] is it a dollar a day for one
razor no no no no no no why they call it
dollar
shave
huh dollar a month
listen man i can't answer every question
it's called dollar shave club yes that
means it costs you a dollar
over the course of your lifetime for one
dollar a month have all your shaving
needs uh met i mean on your face
i feel like
there are people that don't understand
how much magic spoon has changed my life
you know before magic spoon cereal
i was a cannibal i've never even told
you this i didn't know that i used to
eat people
i would eat the skin of a person i would
cook it and eat it
and it's uncomfortable to discuss this
but and a few of those people i i killed
hookers and
truckers
and i would cook them
and i would eat their flesh
which was keto technically maybe not i
think it was some of them had sugar in
their blood probably
when i tried magic spoon cereal i i
stopped doing that i stopped murdering
[ __ ] and eating them
and i started eating magic spoon cereal
and i went to the police and i confessed
and they refused to put me in jail
because they said every they said hey
hey white guy that's what they call me i
said i just killed a bunch of [ __ ] and
ate them they said hey white guy we all
have moments in our life we're not proud
of
they said what made you stop that i said
i'm eating a keto cereal very low in
sugar and i shared it with them we all
ate magic spoon cereal
and uh
and they helped me magic spoon cereal is
the official cereal of the police
[Laughter]
so if you support the cops
support magic spoon cereal
a dollar from every box of magic spoons
cereal is donated to uh derek shelvin's
legal fund
sometimes i do it
just so we get the call
and you know what the kkk stands for
what
hey you know what the kkk stands for
kkk
strike out sportswear i know you thought
it stand for the same company that
[ __ ] kills [ __ ]
hangs us and drags us by trucks but it
really stands for k is like
it's like hold on just i'm sorry
you gotta finish the chips
and make sure you crush them a little
harder there dante
holy [ __ ] this is [ __ ] dumb
this is one of our sponsors
kkk clovers somebody should just gold
and shower you right now this is [ __ ]
up that i should be able to do this and
that's [ __ ] up man
this is bad it's bad if he was up here
reading this [ __ ]
it'd be you think it's for real
headspace man
all right let's be honest most of your
problems start with your mind
fear anger stress oh jesus was i not
telling the perfect story fear anger
stress anxiety depression sleeplessness
they begin in your head
but they can wreck your life
um
please include all of the following
points during your read why did they
write that
i'm going to read everything you wrote
all right
i've said this on numerous episodes okay
but it doesn't have to be that way
you can make a major difference in just
10 minutes a day the change comes
through guided meditation i need this
[ __ ] man
with the new headspace app man
headspace man is meditation made simple
it's guided meditations that you listen
to whenever you want wherever you want
right on your phone computer a tablet
meditation is rooted in thousands of
years of tradition and we're gonna take
that tradition and throw it out the
[ __ ] window and let you do it as you
drive down the highway
um
you know recently i saw a yoga
instructor saying he was quitting it
because like all of the
it's been distilled down to just getting
the [ __ ] killer body you know
anyways with thousands of scientific
studies that show its positive effects
like improving focus and relationship
harmony and decreasing anxiety and
stress join over 5 million users already
getting some headspace man for free
right now
um
i don't understand why i would need to
be able to do it i guess if i'm on the
road
and i'm in the quiet of my hotel room
you know as i listen to the people [ __ ]
on the other side of the wall i i'm able
to block it out through deep breathing
and focusing and quieting my mind
becoming one with the universe
hey they're [ __ ] maybe i'm [ __ ]
too it's a threesome now
download the free headspace fan app and
begin their take 10 program for 10 days
of guided meditation at headspace.com
burr
the headspace take 10 program is 100
percent free
it's percent freeway to experience the
benefit of meditation in your busy
modern life
learn how to read out loud better
without stumbling over your words
train your mind for a healthier less
stressed life
start with your free trial today at
headspace.com
burr that's headspace.com burr
they can't be high-quality razors
they're the highest quality razors in
the world you can split your life
straight somewhere in between
i think it's somewhere in between it
says high quality well it's definitely
high quality high quality rays were sent
to your door it says high quality razors
every month you would be crazy not to
have high quality razors sent to your
house every day
[Music]
[Music]
stay with me till it's dark i'll never
let go
man great is the perfect gift for this
father's day is he alive yeah yeah
a hundred percent made in america if he
was dead it would have been a really bad
moment in the commercial
your dad's alive no
[ __ ]
god damn it
i'm sorry about your dad that's fine
do you know what kkk stands for
i think so
tradition quality and excellence
kkk strikeout sportswear a premium
manufacturer of sports clothing
your father's dead
[Music]
but you have children you are a father
yes and i'm not dead yes maybe you'll
give me one another i'll give you one is
your mom is still alive
my mom yeah no she's dead jesus christ
is any of your relatives [ __ ] alive
this might be my the favorite name of
anything i've ever advertised here
uh other than one white charlie's uh
sherry's berries
it says insert story when you've given
or received
uh the gifts
well i i've been out of town i haven't
gotten sherry's berries yet everybody
all right sherry's berries since the end
of the year is all about delicious
holiday food
why not send an extra special holiday
treat to friends family business
associates
associates everyone you know i've never
met a person who didn't love sherry's
berries
send giant dipped strawberries from
sherry's berries for only 19.99 that's
over a forty percent savings go to
barrys.com click on the microphone and
type in bur b-u-r-r for my listeners
double the berries
for just ten dollars more
berries are terrific and a sweet holiday
gift they also have delicious products
such as christmas cake pops cheesecakes
and dipped pretzels
here's the only way to get
this special 1999 cherries berries offer
call 866 fruit
i'm sorry
what the [ __ ] am i selling
did i approve this this is [ __ ]
ridiculous
who the [ __ ] is gonna buy this [ __ ] this
is the funniest [ __ ] i've ever seen in
my [ __ ] life
christmas cake pops cheesecakes and
dipped pretzels
called eight six six fruit everybody
eats i'm sorry 866 fruit 0-2
or even better
visit barrys.com
oh punch drunk
oh please spell out the words oh by all
means berries b-e-r-r-i-e-s
berries
click on the microphone on the top right
corner and type in bur
you got to see these enormous berries
for yourself
go i swear to god this is the copy go to
berries.com click on the microphone and
tip in bur
typing burr dip your balls and dip your
berries in that don't wait now order
order some chocolate berries for the
[ __ ] person in your life
oh [ __ ] i needed that that was wonderful
i'm sure i'll get some complaints on
that one we need a conference call
can't do it i'm in helsinki
hey you [ __ ] better buy some sherry's
berries because i'm going to get in
trouble with that [ __ ] read and i'm
not changing it because that was
hilarious
um
oh
wiping tears away here
um